Tell us a little bit more about the DNA
extraction step. What actually happen? You get the, the
DNA or the saliva sample in the lab. What, what do you do to get the DNA out?
>> So DNA extraction is very, you know, normal thing that
happens in labs all over the world. There's nothing special about who
we, how we do our DNA extraction. But the process is
really. Trying to separate the DNA in the nucleus of the cell,
from the proteins and other components of the
cell that otherwise would be in the way.
>> I see, and, I mean, how much DNA do
you get out of the saliva sample that someone sends in?
It's actually varying variable. And depending on the person, we can
get anywhere from 10 micrograms to over 100 micrograms of DNA.
>> And does most of that variation happen just based on the
number of cells that were in that spit sample, or saliva sample?
We'd think so, but we actually don't have very good information on that.
We know that some people's saliva is more watery than other people, and we
know that, for example, infants to do not often give us good data,
and we think that's partially because of the wateriness of the, of that saliva.
>> Well, for those people who might be
wondering, you know, what kinds of cells do
you actually getting in my spit, what, what,
what are the actual cells that, You know,
you're extracting DNA from, when you're looking at my saliva.
>> So in a sense it doesn't matter in that almost all of your cells have
your genome in there and it's always the same genome. So we don't look at that,
too closely. We know that the major components
there, are epithelial cells, so the inside of
your cheek, the skin cells there. And the
and white blood cells are the other major component.
>>
Now, I, I, I do floss and brush my teeth.
But I know that I'm sure I have some kind of
bacteria or germs in there. Even still is that a
concern at all, worrying about sort of having other non
me DNA in my spit sample? Again, it's not something
we worry about too much. We know that people have
a lot of bacteria in their mouths, and we know
that from person to person there's huge variability in the composition
of those bacteria. But for amplification we're happy
to amplify up all of your human and
bacterial DNA. And then let the sequencing or
genotyping process sort out the human from the bacteria.
>> I see. So as long as it's human it's good but does that mean like
I, you know, I shouldn't go kiss anybody
right before I, I, I give my DNA sample.
>> For the 23 Me test we actually
collect 2 milliliters of saliva from you which
doesn't sound like a lot but it can take up to five to ten minutes to fill that.
It's a lot of saliva. You would have to
be kissing a lot to make a difference there.